i'm pleased to invite dr uda saksana for
his talk on on his technology in target
selection and drug discovery process
i would like to take the pleasure of
introducing him dr uda saksana is
currently a co-founder of the startup
biotech company reality innovations he
has held executive and leadership
positions at parker davidson and arbor
atherogenics in atlanta as vp drug
discovery dr reddy's laboratory as chief
scientific officer us and india and
cario's therapeutic ceo
he has a phd in biochemistry from
memorial university and post-structural
training at columbia university he was
associated with the team at park davis
pfizer that discovered lipter
and atol was stating the largest selling
peak sales of dollar 17 billion dollars
drug in the pharma business
he let teams that brought several drug
candidates from an idea into the clinic
and we are glad to hear from you sir
over to you
thank you very much
i'm going to tell you about omix
technologies and specifically their
applications in target selection and
really all of the drug discovery process
so briefly i'll talk about i i think i
should introduce drug discovery to this
audience because i'm not so sure what
your backgrounds are so i think i'll go
ahead and do a brief introduction on
what it takes to discover a new medicine
then i will plug into that the role of
omix and clearly omics have a huge role
in discovery of new medicines or drugs
and specifically i want to focus on
proteomics and their its role in drug
discovery
right off the bat i can tell you that 90
percent of the drugs that we have today
have a protein target in other words if
we did not have proteins we would not
have had a drug so that's how important
proteins are in drug discovery and as a
result of that proteomics has certainly
assumed a very important role in
discovery of new medicines
so this is uh to those of you who may
not be aware but discovery of a new drug
is a very long process and where when i
say very long it takes anywhere from 12
to 15 years so the the number one step
that you have to have as we already
talked about in drug disc discovery and
development is you have to select a
target so the target selection the
protein that you want to go after and
its association with the disease has to
be very robustly demonstrated and
convincing so just showing something in
a petri dish and saying i think this is
going to work is simply not enough
because you will that you're setting
yourself for a
failure so
uh everything starts with selecting the
right target so how do omics come into
play here before we had the tools of the
omics like the genomics transcriptomics
proteomics and metabolon metabolonomics
it was a little bit of a hit and miss
but now with these very sophisticated
tools you can actually understand the
disease better i think in summary for
this slide what i want to say it there
is not one step in the drug discovery
process in which we do not use some form
of comics or not so omics have really
really become very important in our
quest for new medicines and drugs
i also want to tell you that
omics are helping us understanding so
one in designing vaccine the other is
designing drugs selecting target i mean
all across the value chain of drug
discovery they're playing a big very big
role now the other big role that omnics
are playing is trying to better
understand the mechanism by which the
drug will work yeah omics have rapidly
become the heart of drug discovery
there's no question protein targets are
the basis of 90 per plus percent of the
drugs
as you can see mutations in the protein
targets can cause dramatic changes
escape mutations
and proteomics is pretty much useful in
target selection drug selection
mechanism action so long story short uh
you know long live omics because of
omics i think the likelihood of success
of drug discovery is going to
dramatically increase so thank you very
much for your time
[Music]